ihr seht schon im titel eingeblendet
meine damen und herren ich hätte heute
im neuen cod activision hat einen neuen
call of duty teil raus gepasst und zwar
spielt dieser im zweiten weltkrieg und
ich habe jetzt einige zeit danach
gesucht mehrere tage ist das wird schon
draußen und ich habe eine textdatei
gefunden haben cod heck und dies 0 byte
groß und ich würde sagen wir machen auf
diese datei jetzt einfach mal einen
doppelklick und wir sehen schon die
details bisher noch leer aber diese
datei ist magisch das heißt wir geben
jetzt hier einfach mal einen
schrägstrich hilfe von crafter best
unterstrich skills unterstrich er war
das muss man groß schreiben sonst weg
der hack nicht an drücken wie renter
enter unterstrich ex unterstrich und
nochmal enter und geben dann das spiel
ein in dem das ganze stattfinden soll
de www 2 wir schauen jetzt mal ingame
ob's geklappt hat wir befinden uns jetzt
hier in game ich bin jetzt einfach mal
hier in einer team deathmatch lobby
reingegangen bei team deathmatch geht es
darum dass zwei teams gegeneinander
blumen pflücken und wer am ende mehr hat
gewinnt wir werden jetzt einfach mal
schauen ob unser heck wirklich
funktioniert hat jetzt geht's dir los
freude kommt man hier direkt an das war
natürlich jetzt das lag noch nicht am
heck also wir sind jetzt auf jeden fall
ingame können uns das ganze jetzt mal
anschauen das geile ist durch den hack
habe ich jetzt quasi kommt wir laufen
jetzt einfach mal hier unten durch
ducken oder irgendwie so was brauche ich
halt nicht weil ich habe ja den hacker
am start das heißt da kann eigentlich
überhaupt nichts passieren da oben kommt
oh mein gott okada verstecke ich mich
doch lieber ein bisschen vor also hier
sollten jetzt gleich gegner rauskommen
das geil an im heck ist halt dass ich
jetzt wirklich unfassbar ins geld war
robben das ist eigentlich schon ganz gut
ich habe jetzt hier so eine kleine waffe
oder auch all diese große und das geile
ist ich kann jetzt wirklich auf dieser
map rumlaufen sehen da oben den gegner
und ihr seht schon den habe ich jetzt
nicht getötet es geht los wie sie da
sind zwei flaschen kommen her kommt
hahaha ich will am liebsten die grafik
ich mal ein bisschen runter stellen weil
mein pc es jetzt auch nicht so ultra 3d
ist es denn sein ernst und kann das
wirklich komplett egal sein mit find am
boden oder keine ahnung was irgendwie ab
geht also ich habe ja den hack am start
das heißt wir haben hier auf jeden fall
oho das ist eine schöne waffe macht spaß
das spiel ich kann deppen hier seht ihr
auch geht nur mit dem heck ich glaube
jetzt mal hier unten lang ist immer
richtig krawall da geht es mega ab genau
da steht man auch manchmal jetzt mal
ganz vorsichtig hier vorgehen genau
jetzt sehen wir davon ab was warum
bisher wirkt der hack noch nicht so
richtig aber wir können zumindest sehen
dass ich bin letzter ja ach ich hab die
tastenkombination vergessen man musste
mich hier in den chat gehen muss sagen
heck activated genauere enteilt sehen
wie lukas aktiviert und jetzt geht's ab
freunde zweiter kill freunde jetzt ist
der erhalt aktiviert da geht es jetzt um
jetzt gibt es mal richtig ab hier
jako haben das war jetzt gerade weil ich
den hack kurz ausgemacht hatte weil ich
wollte jetzt nicht dass es irgendwie die
gegner merken
okay der luca der hack hier irgendwie
das will man ja auch nicht so gern
deswegen was jetzt mein plan ist sich
gibt ab jetzt wieder ein hacker in
hackney wendet guck da vorne steht ein
typ sagt direkten abschluss gemacht soll
den hack lassen jetzt einfach mal an ich
meine am liebsten willigten ausmachen
und würde euch zeigen dass ich auch so
relativ gut wird sagt haben wir direkt
den nächsten abschluss gar kein problem
ist noch nicht mehr letzter wir sehen
zum loch von f das war der jetzt los
konnte ich jetzt mit meinem heck
tatsächlich auch nicht verhindern tut
mir leid dass ihr sehen musste wie ich
mit solchen volltrottel nimmt ihm hier
verlieren verloren
verliebt verlobt verheiratet ich habe
mir immer gedacht hey komm ich musste
ihn ja beibringen wie es wie es geht
ich fühle mich da halt auch so ein
bisschen so wie der der lehrer von luca
wie kommt gleich einer raus das merke
ich wegen meines ex ja aber das war ja
erst mal der erste kind von denen
deswegen werde ich jetzt erst mal hier
er kann nicht mehr denken dass sie unten
wissen die wenigsten hier war wurde
früher wein gelagert und deswegen immer
wenn man dadurch läuft sind die gegner
betrunken
jeder mitarbeiter von activision denkt
ich bin der jüngste mensch der welt ich
glaube jetzt mal hier hinten wiederum
nämlich genau da wurde schon von der
seite angeschlossen habe einfach nur
weil ich deren wein halt geklaut habe
aber ich warte jetzt hier auf den typen
der kommt ja ziemlich gleich hindurch
doch da man band paar sekunden später
scheiße aber ich pflege so gern zu sagen
meine damen und herren wenn ich einmal
getötet werde dann werde ich kein
zweites mal getötet also ihr seht schon
hier eingeblendet wird was was das für
ein mensch alter was ist das für ein
mensch und vieh hat geruckelt o mein
gott alter komme keiner kann mich hier
mir irgendwas wir befinden uns wieder im
weinkeller freunde das heißt wenn man
hier raus kommt sind die gegner alle
betrunken gewissen bescheid bisher
keinen abschluss wo mein gott ok jetzt
warten oder schon tot
doch manet
da melde mich wieder den ersten kinder
hackett wieder an freunde kill nummer
zwei soll freund jetzt müssen wir das ja
alles immer so ein bisschen wieder
alleine regeln gegenüber 38 abend wir
haben gewonnen
wegen meinem heck das was jetzt in
familie meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat dass nicht mal wieder
cod gespielt habe ich mein letztes video
von cod hat irgendwie bei eine million
aufrufe bekommen deswegen dachte ich mir
auf jeden fall hält kommt nächstes mal
wieder hoch hexte mal wieder ein
bisschen vorletzter diesmal und jetzt
meine damen und herren kommen das worauf
glaube ich jeder den ganzen tag immer
nur wartet bei einem neuen video von
luca und zwar das outro weil jetzt ist
halt endlich mal vorbei das war so das
war's jetzt ihr vom video hier können
jetzt hier mal den kanal abonnieren oder
hier unten meinen job ausschenken hier
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ich schon abonnent sein könnt ihr auch
die glocke klicken dann willkommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]